we talked yesterday about a Saudi woman
being arrested for wearing a miniskirt
we've since learned that she has been
released without charges as of right now
I got a call yesterday from a Saudi
woman on our voicemail line which is two
one nine to david p a saudi woman who
said you it's actually worse than you
even imagined in saudi arabia take a
listen to this hi David um females from
Saudi Arabia and I was just watching
your segment about the woman that got
arrested for wearing a skirt I've been
living in the United States for over ten
years now
and my name is RA I'm not going to give
my full names as that's not smart being
from Saudi Arabia and I thank you for
bringing that issue up and the reality
is much worse than you think growing up
there was a really challenge in time and
it shipped me in a way that I wouldn't
really take back but I do not need to be
a warrior to reach my potential so thank
you for bringing it up and keep it up
you have a great show thank you thank
you really appreciate that and you know
when you have such a closed system it's
not surprising that what we hear about
is only a fraction of the total of what
there is to hear about we've got a
tremendous bonus show for you today the
White House yet again continues to
bungle people's names we have a member
of India's lowest caste expected to be
elected president and NASA wanted to
talk about science and a congressman
wanted to ask instead about Martian
civilizations we've got a fantastic
bonus show get instant access to the
bonus show by signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership i'll speak
to you then